well hi everybody the knights are off to
their best start ever
in four years as a franchise a 4-0
record looks pretty good right now
now you may recall it was one year ago
this week
that the knights made a surprising
coaching change gerard gallant was out
pete deboer formerly of the sharks was
taking over
although the last year man it feels like
10 years packed in one with
with everything that's gone on
no doubt a lot has happened in the world
and for the knights in this year since
deboer first took to the ice
with the knights on that canadian road
trip three training camps
essentially the bubble experience and
obviously getting going again here now
from a personal uh vantage point moving
and moving and
and trying to get comfortable during a
worldwide pandemic so
there's been there's been a lot packed
into the last 12 months
the next step for the boar is keeping
the team on track and seeing fans return
to t-mobile arena
everybody's looking forward to turning
the page on a new year and
and getting things back to normal and
play in front of our home crowd in
in t-mobile and get back to work
well the work continues for the knights
with their first road trip
of the season they play at arizona
friday